en hierba la policía acordona los
alrededores de la sinagoga gripa tras el
atentado del martes por la noche en
estas imágenes se ve el pánico por los
disparos entre las personas que estaban
al interior de la sinagoga un ataque
perpetrado en dos etapas
[Música]
primero un gendarme de la guardia naval
tunecina mató con un arma de fuego a uno
de sus compañeros y se llevó su munición
después se dirigió A los alrededores de
la sinagoga una de las más antiguas de
África donde cientos de judíos se
reunían para la última noche y la
peregrinación anual de la griba
el agresor disparó hacia el lugar
sagrado el atacante murió por disparos
de la policía
esta sinagoga en la que se mantiene una
seguridad extrema ya había sido blanco
de un atentado en 2002 cuando un
vehículo bomba mató a 21 personas
según los organizadores del encuentro
cinco mil judíos participaron en la
peregrinación este año los fieles
procedían principalmente el extranjero
en túnez la comunidad judía se ha
reducido considerablemente según el
último censo Sólo hay 1.500 judíos en el
país frente a los 100.000 que había
antes de la independencia en 1956